When we solve this radical equation, p should equal positive 8. Nice thinking
if you got this one correct. When raising this left hand side to the 2nd power,
we'll be left with the expression underneath the radical. So we'll just get p
plus 1. On the right hand side, we'll square 3 to get a value of positive 9. We
subtract 1 from both sides to isolate p, so 1p equals positive 8. One thing we
want to do with radical equations is always check our answer. Sometimes this
answer won't work in the original radical. Because sometimes it makes this
radicand negative. We don't want that to be the case, so we can take the square
root. So let's check for 8. We'll replace p with the value of 8, take the
square root of 8 plus 1, which is 9, and that equals 3. We come out with a true
statement on the end of 3 equals 3. So yes, this is the correct answer.